heart disease is the number one killer
of women but a new survey in the Journal
of the American College of Cardiology
found it is not a top priority for women
or their doctors cardiovascular disease
causes 400,000 deaths a year and that is
more than all cancers combined think
about that for a second 45% of women are
unaware of the danger our dr. Tara
Narula is a cardiologist at the
northwell health and she joins us this
morning at the table to discuss because
this Tara is important in its big a lot
of women say that they want to lose
weight before they go to the doctor they
say they'd much rather do their taxes
and go to their doctor how can this be
when heart disease is so important and
so prevalent for women it is killing one
woman every 80 seconds and yet women
don't recognize that this is their
biggest threat so one of the barriers is
that it's just not real for a lot of
women they say I'm in shape I'm too
young I don't have a lot of risk factors
in fact in this survey many said I don't
really know any woman who's had heart
disease so it needs to become more of a
real threat to them needs to become
personalized that's one barrier another
barrier is certainly the social stigma
that you mentioned which is a lot of
women feel that if they talk about heart
disease with their doctor they might be
looked down upon in a sense that will be
judged they'll be judged that they don't
eat right that they don't exercise and
so in fact 45% of women in the survey
said they wanted to lose a few pounds
before they went to the doctor so they
could be their best self and that sounds
crazy but that's how these women are
thinking about it other issues women
tend to downplay their symptoms I can't
tell you how many times women tell me
well it's just pret it's just stress
it's just stress I'm sure or they don't
recognize their risk factors or symptoms
you know 40% of women who have a heart
attack never had chest pain they can
present atypically with nausea anxiety
jaw pain so it's important that we make
that awareness known so how often should
we be screened for heart issues so this
should be a conversation that happens at
every visit in fact the American Heart
Association recommends the women start
having what they call a well woman visit
annually where you talk about risk
factors you get screened one of the most
interesting things about this survey is
that doctors primary cares and
cardiologists felt unprepared to deal
with women and cardiovascular health and
that's a problem in fact they weren't
prioritizing it they were prioritizing
in this survey weight issues and breast
health not cardiovascular disease tell
why is that a problem at this point
we've heard about this for years the
doctors tend to look at men for heart
disease but not women why haven't
doctors gotten the message that's a
great question I mean it has been under
researched underfunded under studied in
general and I think one of the big
issues of this survey is to raise
awareness and doctors that they need to
be screening women every single visit
they need to be talking about this not
waiting for their patients to bring it
up because 71% of the women in the study
waited for their doctor to bring it up
and if the doctor didn't bring it up it
didn't get discussed so it needs to be a
discussion happening at every visit
women can have respecters that are
particular to them to that they don't
often think about depression anxiety
autoimmune diseases like rubus lupus
rheumatoid arthritis pregnancy
complications so important to understand
the whole picture and bottom line and
overwhelming majority of heart disease
is preventable it is that is the good
news thank you always good to have you
here dr. taryn urilla thank you